but really now as an adult and for you
in this position where you're saying you
have your own skittishness and
nervousness about really diving in
um i imagine that you have trust issues
and also feel really nervous
truly opening up and being your full
self with someone
god you're good thank you okay so how do
we begin to unpack these things for each
other
and figure out like what is your
motivation is your
saying well i want to make sure it's
absolutely the one is that actually just
an avoidance tactic to
prevent being intimate with anybody
god i knew this would turn around on me
yeah it probably is it's a defensive
defense mechanism i think i mean because
there's no perfect one out there there's
just
they don't exist i'm not perfect and
neither are you well you're
closer than i am you're very kind
perfection uh
and ryan here but um well ryan's
obviously perfect except for the fact
that he doesn't know how to use a
microphone
yeah exactly this is accurate
[Laughter]
um i i don't know let me ask you what
what is now going from this 21 year old
girl really girl to
how do you feel about it how do you feel
about marriage how do you feel about
i mean do you want to get married
largely i feel great about it
but again i think it depends on what
people's motivations are and i want to
make sure
whether it's myself or one of my best
friends that we're clear on
what it is we're signing up for rather
than thinking we're getting some
like you know kate hudson and matt
mcconaughey uh
rom-com life you know this notion that
you're going to meet your person
and they're going to make you so happy
that you're going to be fulfilled
and you'll never be nervous again and
you'll never ever think anyone else is
hot
like what it's such an absurd
uh joke and so what i
am a fan of when i'm a believer in is
real partnership real
intimacy that comes with radical honesty
and with ground rules of always giving
your partner the benefit of the doubt
while asking questions while
being able to be vulnerable admit when
you're afraid admit when you're being
triggered by something else like
you have to do a lot of work that sounds
i mean it sounds the first thing i
thought of was
this needs to be a course in college oh
i agree seriously
they would just really sit down and talk
to you about look these are the things
and i think earlier i had a really
fascinating conversation with esther
perel who was talking about certain
countries
um that begin empathy education
in preschool and every couple of years
there's more curriculum which
is about um holding space for each other
and what what consent means we don't hit
our classmates if you want to hug
someone ask those kinds of things for
little kids
that steadily evolve into sex ed in
you know whether it's middle school high
school i don't know when they do that
for kids anymore
um clearly we're doing a terrible job of
it uh
so that it's it is about consent it is
about intimacy it is about
sexual safety and and and they
learn about relationship building
from the time that they're you know for
can you imagine if we'd had 14 months oh
my god oh my god
you know i just never existed with me
all i saw i was surrounded by just
dysfunction and i didn't
so imagine at a young age if you had
because in the developmental years
when you're five seven whatever it is if
you're not receiving love and all these
things that you should be receiving as a
young
kid yeah it changes the whole outcome it
really does and you don't know what that
is and you're
i think that's what a lot of people do
go through i mean unless you have really
great parents and you know
um i don't know sounds like you had a
great experience with that i mean
my parents and i have done the work we
had years that weren't
great